how's it going Reza this week we're
gonna draw your fan fiction fantasy I
tweeted out who do you ship with who let
me know and I'll draw it people are like
me and you first of all this is not you
how am I gonna time I gonna draw this
girl that is not you and you don't even
follow me where the [ __ ] would I draw
you in louis tomlinson all right what do
we got we got Hitler and Beyonce we have
the answer and Hitler no wait I mean
Hitler and Beyonce I'll just use these
as reference so I'm drawing with my
mouth so like don't hate he has one to
forehead Lee did he have a butt cheek I
feel like he should have a butt cheek
and then we have Beyonce famous for her
big Beyonce it's this to sexualize for
YouTube I can't even tell these days and
she be like to the left Hitler and
Hitler be like darlin Beyonce's actually
pregnant in this fanfiction and Hitler
is actually holding their previous baby
Beyonce Hitler who is she dating into JC
JC still a little jealous about the
situation yes that is the face of
jealousy right there and there and there
and they're very very you habit the ship
has sailed
beautiful luckily no one will ever see
that I made this let's see what else
amazing suggestion you boys come up with
Oh Dan and Phil how are you how are you
know I didn't just draw that in the
other video or anything
goddamn Dan and Phil they're [ __ ]
everywhere all right let's do I mean
just look at them looking at each other
sock yacht they are like made for each
other
oh man this is good [ __ ] man
Obama's reaching for that titty why is
it so hard to draw it's not fair I'm Lee
I'm trying all right god damn it
oh yeah it's actually wearing a bra Kim
Jung likes to collect bras what the [ __ ]
is wrong with my life why am I doing
this supposed to draw fanfictions this
is just straight-up erotica need more
Chin's okay so the story is that the war
it led to a nuclear war between obama
and kim young and kim young lost his arm
and his penis so it had to be replaced
by a fish and the world is ending with
nuclear blasts going on here in the
background but now they finally now all
the tension is gone they might as well
just have a final kiss
what's the ship name here kim jama got
it
the ship has sailed but what is this a
new ship has entered the harbor the Pope
and Lady Gaga I'm going to hell again I
don't know what the [ __ ] happened I can
make sense out of this
you know how Lady Gaga was like rumored
to have a penis and then he turned out
not to be true what if she was a penis I
don't know what that is I don't want to
know what that is
god damn no no no no it's probably
probably better if I don't the ship has
sailed
Oh a new ship has entered the harbor
spinch bub and slender man see I can do
that no one will be offended by that
that's great
more like slender ass so spongebob
actually collected all the pages here
and the reward for that is that you get
to see his Slendy the ship sailed a new
ship Ken and milk
I'm guessing they mean cinnamon toast
ken okay Ken always have his beer hatch
[Music]
stupid ugly hat I'm just kidding I'm
sorry okay I mean it's beautiful
he has his little beard there we go
and I bet you're wondering how is the
milk it gonna come into this L just wait
just wait
you know what comes from nipples yes I
don't see how this is the ship I don't
see how this is anything hashtag kill
the ship is sale
[Music]
Lucan Callum becomes cake wasn't that
just the cutest [ __ ] thing I ever
heard they're doing the peace sign this
gives me inspiration oh it's going to be
dirty look at that
it's like a it's like he's wearing a
hedgehog I'm really not that good at
drawing meatballs I'll admit that much
[Music]
Callum lost his arms from all the bad
play
so really the peace sign represented
that they wanted to to scissor that's
that's where my brain went I'm just
trying to think like a fangirl they're
actually scissoring on stage and all the
fangirls they look like penises god
dammit and the other band members
started filming it so they can release
it in their documentary behind the
scenes footage there we go cake the ship
has sailed
[Music]
Trek and Justin Bieber shrek is really
[ __ ] tired of [ __ ] Justin Bieber
so Shaq was I alright this time you [ __ ]
me so strict slowly pull down his pants
and revealed that giant anus and Justin
Bieber was like but there's no Photoshop
what do I do
how can i satisfy this beautiful but
without Photoshop but I just draw Justin
Bieber's penis that's not accurate he
doesn't have one I'm skating so Justin
Bieber runs away crying ship has sailed
I hope you enjoyed this video if you
want to see more fanfiction being
shipped please do leave a like thank you
for watching as always I really
appreciate it and as always it's just
gotta come abroad today
straight awesome rice
[Music]